BRIAN KILMEADE.
HERE FROM NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
WE ARE KICKING THINGS OFF WITH
OUR 2020 ROUND UP, FIRST UP, IT
HAS BEEN A ROUGH COUPLE OF WEEKS
FOR JOE BIDEN.
AFTER A SERIES OF EMBARRASSING
EMBARRASSING GAFFES, LOOKS LIKE
HE HAS ANOTHER PROBLEM,
OVERCONFIDENCE.
TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> I ALWAYS HAVE DONE VERY WELL
IN STATES LIKE PENNSYLVANIA AND
MICHIGAN.
AND I THINK THAT I HAVE AS GOOD
A CHANCE OR BETTER THAN ANYONE
TO BE ABLE TO WIN IN THOSE
STATES.
AND NO DEMOCRAT HAS EVER WON THE
PRESIDENCY WITHOUT WINNING
PENNSYLVANIA.
I THINK THAT I CAN DO WELL.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN BACKING ON
VOTERS, HOLDING THEIR NOSES AND
VOTING FOR HIM.
BUT IT WILL BACKFIRE.
CHECK OUT WHAT ONE POLLSTER IS
SAYING ABOUT IOWA.
I DID NOT NEED ONE JOE BIDEN
VOTER WHO WAS IN ANY WAY, SHAPE,
OR FORM EXCITED ABOUT VOTING FOR
JOE BIDEN.
THEY FEEL THAT THEY HAVE TO VOTE
FOR JOE BIDEN TO KEEP SOMEBODY
FROM THE LEFT WHO THEY FEEL IS
UNELECTABLE FROM GETTING THE
NOMINATION.
KATIE, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT?
>> Katie: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ENTHUSIASM OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE STILL GOING TO THE RALLIES
THAT BY THE ECONOMY, THIS WILL
BE A PROBLEM FOR JOE BIDEN.
THE THING THAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS IS WHEN
HE ASKS QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS
POLICIES POSITIONS WHEN HE IS
RUNNING AGAINST ELIZABETH WARRE,
HE HAS CHANGE THEM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIS MOMENTUM
GOING INTO THE EARLY STATES, HE
IS SAYING I HAVE DONE WELL IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND OTHER PLACES,
HE HAS NEVER DONE WHILE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DONOR THREATS
FLING AT THRESHOLD THAT HE HAS,
HE HAS BIG DONORS, NOT SMALL
DONORS LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN.
AND SMALL DONORS TURN INTO
GRASSROOTS ACTIVISM, TALKING TO
THEIR NEIGHBORS, TRYING TO
CONVINCE THEM TO GET INVOLVED OR
THINK ABOUT VOTING FOR A CERTAIN
CANDIDATE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THAT,
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS THAT.
I WOULD SAY THAT BERNIE SANDERS
HAS THAT.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT HAVE THAT AT
THIS POINT.
IF YOU REALLY THINK THE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO HOLD THEIR NOSE AND
AS HIS WIFE SAID, VOTE FOR HIM
EVEN IF HE IS NOT THE BEST
CANDIDATE, I THINK THAT HE IS ON
A LOSING PATH FOR SURE.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THAT HE
IS TAKING PEOPLE FOR GRANTED?
>> Juan: NOT AT ALL, HE HAS
EVERY REASON TO BE CONFIDENT.
THINK ABOUT TODAY, HIS ARGUMENT
IS I CAN BEAT TRUMP, RIGHT?
AND HIS ABILITY TO BEAT TRUMP IS
SHOWN IN THE POLLS, BUT LOOK AT
WHAT IS GOING ON TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING BADLY,
THE STOCK MARKET INTO HER MOIL,
CLOSE TO 600 POINTS TODAY, THE
DEFICIT IS SOARING.
AND HE IS FIGHTING WITH
JEROME POWELL, THE FED CHIEF,
SAYS THAT HE IS WORSE THAN THE
CHINESE.
I MEAN, HE IS TELLING AMERICAN
COMPANIES WHAT TO DO AND HE IS
CALLING OTHER PEOPLE'S
SOCIALISTS, I WONDER WHO THE
SOCIALIST IS HERE.
AND YOU GET INTO A SITUATION
WHERE IT LOOKS LIKE, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THE NUMBER ONE CLAIM WAS I
HAVE THE ECONOMY, AND NOW THAT
CLAIM --
>> Greg: YOUR DREAM IS COMING
TRUE, YOU CAN GET A DEMOCRAT.
>> Juan: BUT NOT IN FACT,
JOE BIDEN SAYS IF I CAN WIN, HE
CAN BE SAYING I AM DELIGHTING IN
PROBLEMS, BUT I CAN COME WITH
SOLUTIONS AND TO THIS GUY HAS NO
SOLUTIONS.
>> Greg: HERE'S THE PROBLEM
WITH JOE, THE MORE YOU PUT HIM
OUT THERE, THE MORE JOE GAFFES
YOU GET.
BUT IF YOU KEEP THEM IN THE
SUBZERO FREEZER OUT IN THE
WOODS, THEN HE WILL NOT BE
PREPARED FOR THE STEAMROLLER
THAT IS TRUMP.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THEM OUT THERE,
BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO PUT THEM
OUT THERE, THE STRATEGY IS TO
RETURN TO A SENSE OF CALM AND
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO SAY,
JOE BIDEN WILL MAKE YOU FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE, BUT HIS
SHAKINESS UNDERMINES IT.
SO WHEN YOU COMPARE HIM TO
TRUMP, IT'S FROM GOING TO A
DRAGSTER TO A SHOPPING CART WITH
THREE WHEELS, IT IS SAFE, BUT IT
RATTLES.
AND SOMEBODY BIG COULD MAYBE
ENTER THE RACE, BECAUSE THIS IS
AN EPISODE OF THE LOVE VOTE
WITHOUT CAPTAIN STU OR THE
BARTENDER, IT IS ALL SUPPORTING
CAST, THERE IS NOT EVENTUALLY
THE CRUISE DIRECTOR UP ON THE
STAGE.
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT YOUR GIRL
MARIANNE?
>> Greg: MARIANNE WILLIAMSON
IS THE ONLY PERSON WHO COULD DO
THIS.
CALL ME, MARIANNE.
>> Jesse: AND JUAN MASTERFULLY
TRANSITIONS TO DONALD TRUMP.
I DO HAVE TO MENTION THAT HE
TWEETED THAT HE IS SLAPPING
ADDITIONAL TARIFFS ON CHINA AS
THE MARKET CLOSES.
>> Martha: WHEN YOU MAKE YOUR
ARGUMENT FOR JOE BIDEN'S
CANDIDACY, IT IS ALL ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Juan: THAT IS WHAT HIS
CAMPAIGN IS.
>> Martha: I GET IT, BUT YOU
NEED SOMEBODY WHO IS INSPIRING
IF YOU WANT TO UNSEAT AN
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE
THAT IN HISTORY AS RONALD REAGAN
AND BILL CLINTON.
THINK ABOUT HOW DYNAMIC THOSE
CANDIDACIES WERE, THAT IS NOT
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW IN
THE STATES.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE A VERY BIG FACTOR FOR THE
CANDIDATES AND FOR JOE BIDEN IN
PARTICULAR, BUT IN TERMS OF
INSPIRATION, LIFTING THE NATION
IN A POSITIVE MESSAGE THAT WAS
REALLY INVITED BY THOSE TWO
CANDIDATES COMING YOU'RE NOT
SEEING IT HERE.
>> Jesse: IT LOOKS LIKE SOME
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS ARE
VOTING FOR BIDEN AS A DEFAULT.
NEXT, BERNIE SANDERS CALLED OUT
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AFTER
ROLLING OUT HIS $16 TRILLION
GREEN NEW DEAL.
IT TURNS OUT THE SOCIALIST IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A HYPOCRITE WHEN
IT COMES TO CLIMATE.
WATCH.
>> YOU SEEM ADAMANT ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> OF COURSE.
>> WHAT WAYS WOULD YOU TAKE TO
PRACTICE WHAT YOU PREACH IF YOU
ARE PRESIDENT?
>> NO, I'M NOT GOING TO WALK TO
CALIFORNIA.
I UNDERSTAND, WE DO THE BEST
THAT WE CAN AS AN EXAMPLE.
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO SIT HERE
AND TELL YOU, I'M NOT GOING TO
GET ON A PLANE.
I'M NOT GOING TO COME OF THAT
WOULD BE TRUE.
>> Jesse: IT SEEMS LIKE PEOPLE
LIKE BERNIE HAVE A HIGHER
THRESHOLD, MARTHA, WHEN IT COMES
TO WALKING THE WALK.
>> Martha: ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN I WATCH THAT MOMENT, IT
REMINDED ME OF WHEN WE DID OUR
TOWN HALL WITH BERNIE SANDERS
AND IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT HE
MADE OVER A MILLION DOLLARS ON
HIS BOOK.
AND I ASKED HIM, YOU SAY THAT
MILLIONAIRES AND BILLIONAIRES
SHOULD PAY MORE ON THEIR TAXES.
WOULD YOU VOLUNTEER?
TO WALK THE WALK, TO SAY, I
SHOULD BE PAYING MORE, BECAUSE I
AM NOW A MILLIONAIRE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID HE SAY?
I FORGET.
>> Martha: HE WAS MEAN, FIRST
OF ALL, HE SAID, WHY DON'T YOU
PAY MORE?
I SAID I'M NOT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE DOES NOT LIKE TO BE PRESSED
ON THESE ISSUES THAT HE FEELS
STRONGLY ABOUT.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE RIGHT, THAT
IS HIS BIGGEST WEAKNESS.
WHEN YOU ACCUSE HIM OF
HYPOCRISY, HE GETS VERY
DEFENSIVE.
>> Greg: HE BETTER CALL UP THE
OBAMAS, BECAUSE THEY PURCHASED A
$12 MILLION MANSION ON THE
COAST.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE DEMS, THAT
COAST WILL NOT BE THERE IN TEN
YEARS.
SO THE OBAMAS KNOW SOMETHING
THAT THE DEMS DON'T?
THAT IT IS ALL B.S., WHICH
STANDS FOR BERNIE SANDERS.
THE SECRET OF BEING A
PROGRESSIVE IS TO BE ON TOP.
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE ON TOP, THEN
YOU CAN ENFORCE YOUR BELIEFS
WITHOUT EVER HAVING TO ADHERE TO
THEM.
AND WHEN PEOPLE COME AFTER YOU,
YOU CAN BE LIKE BILL de BLASIO
AND GO, YOU KNOW WHAT, I HAVE
EVERYBODY ELSE TO OBEY AND SACRI
EVERYBODY ELSE TO OBEY AND SACRE
WHICH ALLOWS ME TO GO TO THE GYM
IN BROOKLYN WITH AN ENTOURAGE,
OR WITH BERNIE WHO OWNS THREE
HOMES AND FLIES PRIVATE OR FIRST
CLASS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S LIKE
BILL BARR, BECAUSE HE CAN WAIT
OUT A RECESSION WITH HIS MONEY.
>> Katie: I REMEMBER WHEN
BAIDOA WORKS FINANCIALS CAME OUT
AND THEY WERE LIKE, WHY DON'T
YOU DONATE MORE TO CHARITY
BECAUSE YOU ARE FROM A WEALTHY
FAMILY.
AND HE BASICALLY SAID I AM THE
GIFT.
I AM RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT TO DO
THE MOST GOOD.
AND BERNIE SANDERS WANTS TO
CONTROL EVERY INDUSTRY, SO THAT
THE LITTLE GUY HAS TO BAKE THEM
FOR WHATEVER THEY NEED.
HE IS THE GUY THAT SAID THAT
BREAD LINES IN NICARAGUA WAS A
GOOD STATE.
HE IS NOT STANDING IN THOSE
LINES.
>> Jesse: THAT IS NOT TRUE,
JUAN, THAT WAS A JOKE.
>> Juan: I LISTEN TO YOU TOO
MUCH.
I'M SO CURIOUS, BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO ME WHEN I LOOK AT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BACKING DONALD TRUMP,
THE BIG DONORS ON TOP.
>> Martha: THEY ARE NOT TAKING
IT AWAY FROM EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> Juan: DONALD TRUMP IS DOING
GREAT WITH THE STEVE ROSSS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE.
THE >> Greg: AND THE LITTLE
DONORS, 50%.
>> Juan: YOU LOOK AT THE MONEY
THAT COMES FROM TAX, GREG.
HE HAS A HUGE LEAD, BUT TO GET
BACK TO BERNIE FOR A SECOND.
ALL OF YOU ARE NOT UNDERSTANDING
THAT BERNIE IS NOT PLAYING SMALL
BALL.
HE IS TALKING TRANSFORMATIONAL
POLICY ON ISSUES THAT THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOTHING TO SAY
ABOUT.
>> Greg: AND THEN HE WILL BE
THE NOMINEE, AS I PREDICTED.
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS DO NOT FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT HE WILL NOT BE
EASILY PORTRAYED, HE
HIMSELF A SOCIALIST, AND WHAT
DOES TRUMP WANT?
>> Greg: NO MORE ENERGY WISE
THAN JOE.
>> Katie: THE WAY THAT YOU
CHANGE BEHAVIOR ON POLLUTION AND
ENVIRONMENT IS TO DO IT ON AN
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL AND IF
BERNIE SANDERS CANNOT CUT BACK
ON ANYTHING WHEN HE SAYS WE WILL
TEXT YOU OUT OF THE WILD ZOO AND
TAX THE MIDDLE CLASS, SUE THE
OIL COMPANIES, TAKE OVER THE
GOVERNMENT WITH THE OIL
COMPANIES FOR NO CRIME THEY HAVE
COMMITTED AND HE IS NOT WILLING
TO SAY ONE THING HE WILL DO.
>> Jesse: FINALLY, LIZ WARREN
ALMOST DID THIS AGAIN.
♪ ♪
>> Jesse: APPARENTLY LIZ DID
NOT LEARN HER LESSON AFTER BEING
MOBBED AT THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
LUCKILY SOMEBODY STOPPED HER
FROM ANOTHER EMBARRASSMENT.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: USING CHILDREN AS
PROPS.
>> Katie: 11 IN THE ARTICLE IT
SAID SHE APPEARED SHE MIGHT HAVE
TRIED TO DANCE.
IT APPEARED THAT SHE MIGHT HAVE
AND IT'S MAKING ME LIKE A LITTLE
LITTLE BIT MORE.
SHE IS JUST VERY, SHE'S JUST
TRYING TO DANCE.
I FIND THIS MUCH MORE ENDEARING
THAN DOG, DO YOU WANT TO HAVE A
BEER WITH ME?
>> Greg: HERE IS THE ISSUE,
THEY ARE CHOOSING THE WRONG
MUSIC, CHOOSE INSPIRATIONAL
MUSIC YOU CANNOT DANCE TO.
LIKE SOME GOOD DEATH METAL WILL
BE GOOD.
EVERYBODY THINKS THAT THEY CAN
DANCE TO THIS SONG, AND THEY
CAN'T.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO KICK MARTHA MacCALLUM OFF
AT THEIR SHOW.
SHE IS TOO NICE.
SHE IDENTIFIES WITH THE
STRUGGLES OF THE CANDIDATE ON
STAGE IN A WAY TO RATIONAL WAY
FOR US.
>> Jesse: SHE IDENTIFIES WITH
SOMEONE WHO CAN'T DANCE.
>> Martha: NO, I CAN DANCE.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE NOT SEEN
PROOF OF THAT.
CAN WE FIRE UP SOME R-EE-S-P-E-
C-T?
>> Katie: I DON'T WANT TO
BULLY HER ON HER DANCING.
IT'S FINE.
>> Juan: GREG, CAN YOU SAY